تتدفق الحشود إلى بلدة
جاور ميسوري الصغيرة لمشاهدة جثة راهبة كاثوليكية
يبدو أنها لا تظهر عليها علامات
التسوس على الرغم من دفنها لمدة أربع
سنوات ، تم استخراج جثة شقيقتها ويلمينا
لانكستر التي توفيت في عام 2019 عن
95 عامًا من الدير.
حتى يمكن نقلها إلى
مثواها الأخير داخل
الكنيسة ، ولكن عندما اكتشفوا نعشها ، فإن
هذا ما وجدوه يبدو أن جسد لانكستر
كان سليمًا على ما يبدو ، وهو ما
يعني في التقاليد الكاثوليكية أن الجسد
لم يتحلل
لشركة CNN التابعة لـ KMBC.
البلد الذي يرى
بأنفسهم
تجربة قوية للغاية ، إنه أحد
أكثر الأحداث ندرة في الولايات المتحدة بأكملها ،
ليس بهذا العمر ، لكنني لم أسمع
بذلك مطلقًا في حياتي ، لقد سارت على ما يرام حقًا
ذهبت لترى بنفسك
وأنت  ويمكن للكثير من الناس أن
يروا بأنفسهم لأنها في
الخارج وما الذي جربته
أعني أنه كان مستوى
التفاصيل ملحوظًا حتى أن العلامة التجارية لجوربها كانت لا تزال
مرئية وحجاب عادتها كان
مصنوعًا من نفس الشيء  مادة مثل
البطانة الداخلية للتابوت والتي
تآكلت في حين أن الحجاب لم يكن هناك
أي رائحة فاسدة أو تسوس أو
أي شيء من هذا ، لقد
بدا وكأنها قد
ماتت ليوم واحد